everybody welcome to the Rubin report
I'm the Muslim Brotherhood's favorite
comedian Dave Rubin and we've got two
great guests returning champ
Gina grads second time very happy to
have her and one of my favorite
comedians who I have been harassing
endlessly on the Twitter Andy Kindler
who we even went to the same College
Binghamton University I've ever heard of
it it's a great clown College up in
upstate New York and all right we got a
lot to get to so here we go so Egypt it
changes every moment it will probably
change by the time I finish this
sentence but so there's a lot going on
I'll start at the beginning
you know the Hebrews built the pyramids
and then Moses got them out blah blah
blah then they had 30 years of Mubarak
and the military running then they had a
democratic election Muslim Brotherhood
jumped in and more seed they did not do
anything good actually turn things for
the worse
then we had a coup even though we don't
call it a coup now the military is in
charge again and nobody's happy because
they are killing people left and right
and the Muslim Brotherhood's in it and
are they terrorists or what's going on
let's watch a little videotape and see
how actually how bad things are
so we're seeing tons of that stuff look
that guy didn't look armed was he part
of the Muslim Brotherhood are they
terrorists the military's doing this
stuff we're funding the military is all
of this stuff just over the top like we
can't even fathom this as Americans to
really have a real decent discussion
about it we don't have any sense of
history history in this country also we
don't have I don't have a good visual
thing because I didn't know what was
going on there right I thought it was a
rugby game I had no idea so I apologize
to the families to everyone's going but
the thing is we have no sense of history
here and we have the we've been
controlled by the right wing for so long
so everything is filtered through that
lens so it's like it was up to the right
wing that wouldn't be Muslims you know
right everybody would be into Christian
education camps so it's very very hard
to figure out the thing that bothers me
is is all these pundits not eugenia but
most of these pundits are constantly
they want Obama no matter what happens
it's his fault why doesn't he make a
decision and that's what dry and that's
what drives me nuts because it's such a
difficult thing there's only so much
that we can do in that area yeah there
is only so much we can do and I agree if
the pundits are not helping because
everybody just picks their side and
sticks to it no matter what but is there
a way to have like a really decent
discussion about this understanding a
little history in context and all that
I'd like to do that by saying I have no
idea target audience because I consider
myself pretty well-informed you know my
only two presets in the car FM and AM
talk radio and I listen to this stuff
all day and I still don't understand it
so we're taking it like a little snippet
of what's going on now and widening it
out and saying okay you guys what do you
think but most people don't even
understand how we got to this point so I
don't know you know and I'm gonna speak
as the complete layperson and say I
still don't understand forgive me
why Morsi was ousted if he was
supposedly voted in democratically I'm
confused right I'm super [ __ ]
confused
languages what bothers me no but that's
not the point is is that he was supposed
to bring the country together but the
thing is he I think he was already
cracking down on various rights and was
he imprisoning people who take it away
what he was imprisoning people he was
not giving any of the freedoms that they
had gotten rid of Mubarak for and he was
democratic elected aren't we supposed to
always defend democracy because we
didn't in this case right well I think
we're supposed to do that I think we're
supposed to do the best that we can
under the circumstances
we're hated worldwide you know a lot of
people don't even know that we overthrew
the guy who was in Iran in 1980 he was
elected we said CIA say oh well you came
out this week but we've known about it
forever right and so it's then when 1979
comes along Ted Koppel makes a living
out of going day 72 then you were one
born then day 43 so it's also all of our
anger is focused on certain things and
we don't see the big picture I think we
just try to do the best that we can and
I don't like you know it seems like too
many people got killed I mean anybody
getting killed is horrible but you know
the the Morsi people are also attacking
Christian churches and and there's a
part of there's an element there that
wants to cause revolutionary so
something like 60 churches were burned
why doesn't the Pope say anything about
that that's what I keep thinking is
weird the Pope is always up in
everybody's bedroom and wants to know
what everybody's deal is in my bedroom
last night and when I sang my
fill-in-the-blank right yeah but why
doesn't that really why doesn't the Pope
jump in on this I find it very bizarre
they're they're killing Christians and
they're destroying churches Pope no
quiet I don't get this Pope I I think
he's interesting and everyone said like
oh he's the Francis Pope and he is the
charitable one and he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about all the whatever all this
stuff but is he is he the Obama of popes
well you know and he just kind of wants
everyone to be happy doesn't want to
really ruffle any feathers
he's actually made some nice comment
about gays which is bizarre for a whole
maybe he just kind of wants to stay out
of it he's a new PO but I don't know I
I'm not a people person I like to do
that joke I'm not normally a people
person no but are there Coptic
Christians yeah so is that not under his
Oh anybody it doesn't matter what the
church is he comes that's not my brand
in comment experts here maybe he feels
like he can't maybe because I just want
to flame on either side the Pope right
he does like to flame but not maybe in
this particular part of world but all
right so final question on this are we
just screwed one way or another there we
look we give the money they use the
weapons to turn against their people we
don't give the money and then more
radical people come in so one way or
another is this just typical like
America we just get in everybody's
business and then everyone hates us and
we leave nobody there I think you're
right well you said that we're damned if
we do and damned if we don't if we don't
get involved people are outraged that we
don't care if we get involved it's
America comes and thinks that they can
get in everybody's business and fix
everything but they just make it worse
so I I don't know I think if we can make
things better because first of all I am
a I'm an Obama terian I am in the tank
for Obama I have an Obama outfit at home
I love it I think I've been around
longer than you guys and longer than the
country and I think he's the greatest
he's the best president we've had in my
lifetime it is is he perfect I don't
like some of the things in education so
I feel like he I think that he has tried
to turn around the perception of America
and I think he's gonna but I think he's
in a tough situation but I'm optimistic
I hope in general things will move
better in the world and that was a big
ship to steer I mean you know if people
say like well it's not perfect well you
know it's it takes a welled up to 180
that thing is a ship no charge for the
comedy all right all right here we go
well let's talk we're talking about news
so the the big news in the news world
cuz the news loves talking about the
news is that Al Jazeera America launched
this week and they had a pretty fancy
package they put together to kick it off
it is really effective and in fact
viewership of algae's
going up in the united states because
it's real news we will connect the world
to America and Americans to the world
what Al Jazeera has done has achieved
something that all of us I think want to
achieve and that is to make a
contribution
in an era of consolidation al-jazeera is
expanding investing in a network of
bureaus across the United States
engaging our audience with real stories
about view people in the real world
alright that's some pretty fancy
packaging right there I mean I think
it's kind of hilarious that a news
organization based in Qatar has to be
the one thing that might save American
mainstream media kind of kind of
beautiful alright so there they promised
to do news they're gonna actually do
news not just drivel that we see on our
three cable news channels is it possible
they're gonna save television maybe yeah
I think they're gonna try and they might
even give a really really good old
college try but I don't think people
will watch it because it's called
al-jazeera I was in the public relations
department I'd be like how about Salman
ehre
anything that's not al-jazeera people
are what is it though what is what
people saw that oh here's a top of that
I've heard different things I've heard
from people that they do excellent
reporting I don't know I'm not familiar
enough with them but what what is it
that Al Jazeera
what does it mean principal is it kind
of most people are going to associate it
with the people who ran the Osama bin
Laden you put al in front of anything
and it's gonna Al Queda
yeah but now I'm doing that job for a
boy second now well they showed us that
it's not like they put they didn't say
hey Osama blonde come down in the office
we're gonna do a shoot there they're
just provide they're providing his
message about is that al Qaeda was
giving their tapes to Al Jazeera in
Qatar and we want us to have seen those
richer tapes because Letterman the
funniest thing in the world he would do
is those voices the oh and one more
thing he would do happy birthday to Jane
Fonda a mother thing
death to America come on we wouldn't had
those yeah I can see that but can
alright so I think why didn't they just
call this thing America today network or
their Al Jazeera
so I'm have been worse about wait we're
not algae's
but is it but also something as long as
Anderson Cooper isn't honest it's the
greatest thing in the world
cable news yeah and I'm looking for a
new option yeah I did I wasn't a big
current fan is that what you're we in
their office and say I don't know what
this place is anymore but you can yeah
III wasn't glued so I'm give them a shot
is what I say I'm not gonna make it out
of the studio alive well there are there
are armed security guards at the door
I'm I'm from Kansas yeah I say this the
great unwashed as I am and the owners
lie over Spit States and all of that I
just don't think that that they're gonna
get on board with something called al
Jazeera love it the Midwest is gonna eat
this up you kidding me
their graphics and I love and a piece
for the road and that I was considered
basically a person of color in Kansas I
mean it's not and I can say I really
feel like they're just not gonna get on
board to watch something called al
Jazeera hey everybody Rick come back
from the cornfields early al jazeera's
doing and doing a special yeah close the
gap al Jazeera is doing yes did you guys
see this though one of the things
they're saying is they're they're gonna
actually only have six minutes of
commercials because they want per hour
because they want to give you more news
now of course what they're not telling
you is that it's just because they don't
have an advertiser free they should have
a classic rock station - yeah it's
commercial free what kind of a music
would they play a lot of that sound that
you made during this Farsi and the
cruisers come on people some of these
jokes have written themselves top Farsi
top Farsi station for you yeah all right
so so last thought on this is this just
so I'm you see what I'm tweeting all day
about cable news I mean is this just
that we actually whether this thing's
gonna be good or bad do we just need it
anyway as just a last chance to escape
the crap that we're all being any other
choice I'll watch the BBC world
occasionally I sit with a smoking jacket
and and also I just want to ask you one
thing who's booking this because I'm
working now Jazeera I am ready to go I
will defend the reporting I can put in a
call
they're probably looking for a good
Jewish reporter don't let's let's
undersell the Jewish part will push the
boat yeah
no juice so coca-cola those healthy
people who just want to make you
healthier they are pushing health on us
I just said health 18 times there so
they're doing a new branding thing in
the US and in the UK with print ads and
commercials and all this stuff so this
is some of the video that they're shown
in the UK right now
look about healthy people making healthy
choices granddad died of diabetes right
after that was shot by the way grandpa
died
I think Rambo's dead grandpa drinking a
cold type 1 and type 2 there's a lot of
sugar afoot to that okay we've talked
about this a lot on the show do you know
before we get to the rest of this stuff
that they're not even putting sugar in
our coke in America anyway what we have
high fructose corn soup you want wal
fructose I want sugar I want Mexican
sugar is too expensive for them to put
in our so they get it in Mexico but we
can't get sugar because we're drinking
corn we're actually drinking corn anyway
so they're also releasing all this other
information to show you how good all
this stuff is you better be telling us
all these years but now they're they're
good guys
so they put out this this press release
I like this one the new Coca Cola advert
so is that the lifestyle enjoyed by our
grandparents moving more eating well
taking it easy can be beneficial we're
committed to using our advertising to
raise awareness of importance of energy
balance and helping people to make
informed choices we believe it is just
one of the ways we can help make more
people aware of the need for a balanced
diet and active healthy lifestyle I
really don't know what what are they
talking about grandfather that font that
was not verified by them yeah can I
inform you of two things about coke that
might counter act what they just said
one you know they put a chemical in
coca-cola
that keeps you from vomiting because
there's so much sugar in a coke that it
would make you throw up here comes the
911 truthers B I think that we should
all just use that chemical that you're
you're lying about anti epoch AK I don't
know thank you
but also if you can clean your car
battery with it don't drink it I think
you know that's something that we can
teach our children to not drink anything
off of a battery
okay so what's and know this whole thing
I know friends of mine and they sent me
these things on Facebook sorry which I
don't go to anymore but it's like if you
drink one coke here's what happens it
goes into your intestine
in flames your gallbladder and your
chance of dying no that's not the
problem the problem with that campaign
is Cook has great commercials over the
years we're not gonna be healthy from
coke we enjoy a nice soda don't try and
tell me it's an energy thing just say
look how enjoy it okay I completely
agree why don't they just double down on
you've been drinking this stuff put out
all they're still here we're still here
like why are they even pretending is it
even necessary do Americans even care
whether they're getting fat and obese
and dying of all they say that's a
Harless topic for another day but I
don't I a man tied the whole obesity
thing I think it's the last group of
people that we can pick on there's no
science based on any of these things
that people think you believe me people
way the way they weighed the way their
grandfather best that's a different
thing so you don't think people are
getting fat I don't presume oh yeah well
that well of course they have the same
stock footage of people having people
walking around since the third it's it
isn't billions of dollars in diet fad
things so I don't know that it causes
all those things but I don't know why
they principal coke sales down
well coke say yeah well partly soda
sales in general or down and but now you
know there's things like in New York
City where they wanted to ban big sodas
so the other thing that they're using is
aspartame and aspartame
okay so aspartame is the calorie free
sweetener that was invented in like 1972
it has something to do with Donald
Rumsfeld's family did you know that was
like pushed through the FDA that he was
involved in the anyway they've released
a statement in defending their use of
aspartame our use of high quality low
and no calorie sweeteners including
aspartame allows us to give people great
tasting options they can feel good about
time and again these low and no calorie
sweeteners have shown to be safe high
quality alternatives to sugar in fact
the safety of aspartame is supported by
more than 200 studies over the last 40
years I mean the fact that they said
high quality twice in one short
statement seems weird to me there's some
crazy things about aspartame so you know
people get all kinds of crazy symptoms
from dizziness to memory loss seizures
blinding headaches and even full
blindness so should we be war against
the
the stuff that's gonna keep us thin and
kill us or the stuff that's it's Adam
and stevia not Adam and aspartame all
right
don't would stevia it's natural you're a
big fan of a read-through at all yeah go
with those there's good nap there's good
natural baby is insanely expensive it's
like at Trader Joe's it's like 12 bucks
drinks that are made you don't want to
go with a zero calorie drink they have
drinks that are made that are very tasty
here's my completely flip-flop on you
yeah if I could have Diet Coke given to
me intravenously I would be the first
one to sign up I love it I need it I
gotta have it there's a lot of big
conspiracy theories but I do believe
that there's enough weirdness about
around people drinking aspartame yeah I
would stop it if I were you and I'll
write you a prescription for something
exactly there you go all right next up I
love this story and unfortunately I'm
not on the list that I'm about to talk
about wealth X has come out with a list
of the wealthiest comedians and let's
show the image annoying me we are not on
here Andy I'm sorry here we go so Larry
David is now worth 900 million dollars
Jerry Seinfeld 800 billion Letterman 390
million Cosby 360 and Adam Sandler 290
million just to put that in a little bit
of context Larry and Jerry both made at
least 400 million this year because of
the v syndication agreement first
Seinfeld these guys are rolling in dough
wait listen to this
after the nine-year run that Seinfeld
had on NBC it has netted 3.1 billion
dollars in fees for reruns so that's the
stuff you're gettin on P IX and TBS and
all that I'm gonna start with you on
this one Andy why are you not on the
list well I'm on the list because I
prefer to keep my finances private no I
don't begrudge I have problems with
Larry David on the way on the way the
plots of Curb Your Enthusiasm ago but I
think Seinfeld is up there with the
great shows of all time and it was one
of the last shows Everybody Loves
Raymond was another one where if you
created that show and you produce that
show you made a lot of money so I
begrudge that them their money but Bill
Cosby needs to return some of that just
for his people I don't know why comics
are in love with this guy he said oh I
went to see him he was going on for
three hours just cut it down to 45
minutes the guy rambles he sanctimonious
and in other words that I'd like to use
yeah I have to say in 1983 I saw Bill
Cosby himself on HBO and that is what
got me into love his show
well now he just he just he just sits in
the stool and it's too much rambling and
he's always yelling at people yeah are
these numbers just crazy because
comedians shouldn't comedians be the
every person that are talking about
life's problems and the disproportion of
power in the world and fighting the
power and how can these guys do that
when they're making this I don't think
we should be grudged them their money
just because they're supposed to make
observations about the everyman I mean
it's their right to make the money if I
were Julia Louie Dreyfus or you know any
of the rest of the cast I would probably
consider making a bleach cocktail I may
not but I know that she comes from one
of the wealthiest families you know but
God bless her God go vaya con Dios
because she brought ups - I saw it
because my 13 year old cousin asked me
to take her okay um and she hated it she
thought it was the greatest thing she's
ever seen that is their demographic 13
year old girls 11 year old boys how does
that kind of movie make that man that
much money those guys gonna ever grow up
comedic Lee yeah immediately I say into
my camera blessed Adam Sandler I say god
damn out of there
he's been there I used to love him he
was on Saturday Night Live he did the
Hanukkah song and he's crank it out then
and Chris Rock Chris Rock he did the
movie cuz he fell in love with the money
yeah well okay so that's that's the part
I want to talk about so some of these
guys Letterman who I still think about
money hang I still think that he even
starts robbing but I think Letterman is
I have bro Biff and I I don't have as
many appearance how many parents is my I
don't want to say but I think it's up to
38 I
thirty-eight less than you so but yeah
right so Letterman is still as edgy as
he was and you and Larry David I still
love so is there some thing though with
somebody like Sandler where clearly it's
just become about the money cuz all he's
doing is turning out these things I
think so I think he thinks do you really
I do do you really I don't think he's
very sensitive about how about yeah and
something I'm sorry Gina the one I was
just like Howie Mandel also was on the
Forbes list of people who don't deserve
to be rich don't forget Bobbi's words
the guys on the america's got this flash
bottom in this area and he's been
terrible he's been terrible comedian
serving the comedy community poorly for
over 40 years
Sandler is the most altruistic
philanthropic man in the world because
if you did see grown-ups to which I'm
assuming I'm the only one every every
forgotten cast member from the 90s and
SNL was was given a ball in my moldy
corn
I mean everybody was in this movie and
Tim Meadows a bunch of people some
didn't even have speaking lines but he
wanted to make sure they were all taken
care of apparently yeah so should we
give him a longer leash because of that
because I really like these guys Sandler
specifically well yeah because somebody
like that where even if he's making
crappy movies and he used to be great
and doing all that great stuff on SNL
that at this point he is helping out a
group of guys that never necessarily
really flipped it to the other why can't
he be detained in the London Airport for
nine hours until he admits that he's
making crap now this is anecdotal
because we're not friends but Steve
Martin I thought said that when he
started making like Cheaper by the Dozen
eight and fourteen that he was doing
that more to finance his art collection
and hey you know he's being honest I
love Steve Martin that is an awful
excuse so I can buy fancy art exactly
I'm buying something of good quality by
doing this crap but I appreciate that he
didn't lie about it right I appreciate
that he didn't say but seriously like
Cheaper by the Dozen 42 check it out
it's you're gonna fear it's a life
lesson
and he knows that the excuse they all
make I mean I saw DeNiro at one of the
awards shows he said you know I had to
make Little Fockers because I want to
make some good movies every now and
again well I love the Ben Stiller said
that he was something wanted to meet
Robert De Niro or something like that
and that's why the Fockers thing
wouldn't know wouldn't the dinner have
saved us all a bunch of will you see
Midnight Run then you see how great De
Niro's I don't think i don't believe
that he should be doing although he
recently made it oh he was in that movie
David O'Russell he was great in that
movie you know with Lawrence Jennifer
Lawrence Jennifer Lawrence everybody
he's the brand he's no great he was
supposed to be in the Graduate you know
he turned you again he turned it down
but he's unbelievably brilliant actor
all right well point is I'm pretty sure
that I can speak for all three of us
were available for some of these roles
if someone yeah oh I would be in
grownups three in a second you kidding
me all right let's talk about sex we've
done a whole show without talking about
sex amazingly a new study out of Germany
found that employees who have sex
frequently have significantly higher
salaries than those who aren't getting
laid at work you mean I believe it
includes at work and at home
yeah the study was done for at the
Institute for the Study of labor in
Germany and researchers examined 7,500
household asked questions ranging from
how often they had sex to how much money
they made sections about sexual
orientation religion etc etc let's take
a look at some of the findings people
who have sex more than four times a week
have a 3.2 percent higher paycheck than
those who have sex once a week the link
between sexual activity and wages is the
highest among employees between the ages
of twenty six and fifty okay obviously
the first question to both of you is
when's the last time you had sex
here's the thing good deflection good
well I gotta say you said is the
Institute of labor this is the Institute
of no [ __ ] again because people who have
sex they are happier than more confident
they're you know
there there they have more bravado and
those are the people that make more
money I didn't realize the Germans were
having so much sex because they're like
three times a week compared to one time
there we I mean there's people that have
sex once a week like that's very
exciting yeah sounds good it's low
that's hot that's low that's that's low
my friends my wife my wife and I I
forget it we're sexual dynamos or
machines we can't stop it we can't stop
it with the sex but I told my wife look
I can increase my income even more with
a couple of affairs is what I say to her
even one long lasting affair look at
these figures yeah she won't go for it
she doesn't buy that no backs it up yeah
but that's not done that's me nothing to
my wife yeah okay so I see your point
though is this just that sort of people
you know they always say if you look
better you also get paid more or if you
stand up straighter you get me so this
just all that everything is just basic
superficial nonsense like we do all
these studies but at the end of the day
it's like people like looking at people
and that's why they hire them and that's
why they pay a man it must be a lot of
money in study that's what I'm comes up
with this idea look at this data Germans
that aren't getting laid well German sex
which is very severe that's why that's
why they said and those poor people are
only having sex once a week don't you
matter with you you once a week is is it
as exciting to you you know like oh I
had sex or one dude once that kind of a
with that attitude you're lucky is that
how you are on a date oh I'll never get
on your back with that attitude
I don't know should we have more
sympathy for people that aren't having
sex yeah I mean I don't know let them
unless you're a monk and if you're a mom
if you're a mo good job I say yeah
now links can't talk or have sex that
they can't talk during sex thank you
otherwise they can look or while they're
a gang name I don't know what I'm saying
but they're references and they come
yeah so are you celibate why I just
asked that I basically had nothing to do
with anything
oh I'm sorry I am NOT celibate but I
just I am I am overtaken by these
numbers yeah you're just shocked that
that people are having this much
yeah that actually doesn't I mean this
may lead to my it's not that much sex
with a partner we're talking about
ladies and gentlemen our alone hello if
it was alone we'd all be rolling in
dough all right let's talk about smart
kids and drugs because it turns out that
if you're doing drugs as a kid you're
probably going to be smarter in real
life
studies show a correlation between high
childhood IQs and getting high we're
talking about weed yes using data from
the 1958 national child development
study researchers published a report
last year that found that children who
have higher IQs were more likely to use
illegal drugs later in life again I
believe this was mostly about weed does
this surprise you guys at all it seems
to me that oh I know I think I know some
smart people and I know you're smart and
you're intelligent also smart whether I
use the same word twice know are you
gonna be curious not everybody who's
brilliant like mate but no I mean I
think many people are curious at one
point want to you know do something to
get the juices flowing
yeah parks the Grays drug in the world
except when I spell out my life
insurance policy but it is the great I
don't even know what you're talking
about the character of Andy Kindler
might know right and they do some sweet
damage at Hugo's tacos when I'm high
yeah beautiful damage oh my god I'm
keeping them in business for at least
another four years but I think you're
right I think that a lot of really smart
kids feel under stimulated they get
bored in school they're bored by their
peers because they just they don't
connect with them like they'd like to
because they're they're not on the same
IQ level so they look for other ways to
self-medicate other ways to feel
stimulated and they get high well it
also alcohol to me well I don't drink
because I'm Jewish alcohol syndrome I
just get sleepy so I don't think alcohol
for most people to stimulate you like
your mind so I think things like pot are
different because they actually get you
thinking or eating right so is this one
of those things where it shows how
stupid our war on drugs is that we love
weed in we love weed in with all these
other hard drugs when
in fact and then people see people
stoned and not really doing anything
evil and then you don't the kids can't
make the connection that there's a
difference between drugs so they see
that weed is kind of cool and that you
know these other drugs are probably
goods no anyway you know a lot of that
stuff was political too because you know
a hippie smoke pot so it was it was in
the interest of the government to oh you
know to make those type of things even
more illegal at the time of the best you
know it's after-school specials and
growing pains with the coke party oh
yeah and the we're like well whatever
it's my parents coke and it was like to
be continued and there's no music at the
end of the group but there were so many
of these sitcoms that villainized weed
and I wasn't just saying no Club and
dare and I never got it because he's
pretty great right it's a victimless
drug but that's not a drunk I mean it's
not because guys sorry what does that
mean it's more and more information is
coming out that says it's very now that
people can be addicted to anything and
some people just do get spaced out but
it's you know it's it's helpful in not
just in chemotherapy it's supposed to in
many ways I think is actually going to
be found to be positive for those well
you guys see this the last week dr.
Sanjay Gupta on CNN had a mayor Copa
because after all this time of railing
against weed he finally yeah he's he's
been against even medicinal marijuana
and he finally now did this special
saying I he apologized he actually said
I'm sorry and now he's Pro we right and
for a country and especially a state
that is so woefully under water when it
comes to money why isn't it just a
recreational thing that we can legalize
tax the [ __ ] out of it we don't care
what buy it anyway but you don't want to
make the taxes too high because in the
black market kicks in I just have to
check with Nancy Snyderman and all this
you know what I'm saying dr. Nancy
Snyderman because she's on NBC and she
doesn't know anything
yeah should we not listen are you saying
we shouldn't listen to doctors on
television there are they're absolutely
I like Robert Bazell bet he's one of my
favorites he doesn't he has a problem
with the hands he's I was like but all
these people who sit like every two
years ago salts terrible for you and
then then they
my household is not bad for you and all
these people are the conventional wisdom
junkies and so all they do is tell you
what the conventional is I'm glad I'm
glad Sanjay Gupta is coming around right
I was thinking that Sanjay's thing is he
probably knew this all along but three
years ago it wasn't cool to say you're
down with weed now he sees the times
changing so CNN's like a Gupta what
let's come around on the weed thing
don't you think I mean but I think maybe
he didn't know he wasn't even knew
enough about it because here's this
American guy who got hi Gupta but maybe
it's really that something and he didn't
pay attention to so he bought the the
line I mean you really think those CNN
guys aren't just you don't think wolf
Blitzer's taking on the camera he's in a
situation room can't play around there
yeah that's a lot of pressure to be at
work in a place called the situation but
that's a whole other thing okay guys
thank you for watching thank Andy
Kindler thank Gina Grad subscribe it's
down there I should have said it 20
other times now get out there and have
sex do some drugs
pay attention to Egypt watch out Jazeera
and poke your ego drink coke and there
was one more what was the other one
a lot of overtime and if you're going
into comedy you're gonna make a boatload
of dough okay subscribe we'll do it
again next week